[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo a directo con 26 el
programa especial de france 24 para
debatir lo que ocurre en la cumbre
climática de la onu en glasgow hoy
llegamos a nuestra última emisión que
coincide con el final de esta cita
saludo mis compañeras luisa pulido y
marina colorado que se encuentran en la
sede del encuentro en principio marina
le pregunto en qué van las negociaciones
que se conoce hasta este momento
bueno pues como bien dice se suponía que
hoy terminaba la cop 26 pero puede que
las negociaciones se adentren hasta
pasada la medianoche así que la fecha de
terminación sería el 13 de noviembre y
no el 12 como estaba previsto eeuu y la
unión europea al parecer siguen
bloqueando las negociaciones sobre
pérdidas y daños y sólo apoyan
la creación de un mecanismo de
asistencia técnica pero no la inclusión
de fondos porque no quieren aceptar la
responsabilidad histórica que tienen
como altos emisores de estas emisiones
de gases de efecto invernadero que han
causado tantos daños y pérdidas
precisamente en los países más
vulnerables ya que ellos dicen que si
aceptan esto abriría la puerta a
posibles demandas legales y no quieren
hacerse responsables de esto el único
país que se ha comprometido a entregar
fondos para estas pérdidas y daños uno
de los temas clave ha sido escocia
precisamente donde estamos ahora mismo
que se ha comprometido con una cantidad
simbólica dentro del marco del contexto
de lo que se necesitaría para realmente
hacer huella en los daños y pérdidas de
27 millones de dólares recordemos que 23
de las 197 naciones aquí reunidas son
responsables de la mitad de las
emisiones históricas al acusarme al
presidente de la cat 26 dijo que
seguramente habrá una revisión nueva de
este texto esta noche que se volverán a
reunir
y ojalá consigan aprobar este texto
revisado en algún momento entre hoy y
mañana
louis ahora le pido por favor que
hagamos una recapitulación de lo
acordado hasta ahora
valentina una larga lista y lo cierto es
que estos acuerdos paralelos no van a
quedar consignados en el gran acuerdo de
glasgow incluso algunos tienen carácter
de histórico voy a empezar con el metano
se han comprometido algunos países a
reducir el uso del metano para el 2030
esto es bien importante porque este
combustible marina tú mejor sabes es
responsable por el calentamiento global
en un 25 por ciento también anuncios muy
importantes compromisos para acabar con
la deforestación al año 2030 esto es
bien importante porque los países
firmantes más de 100 cubren el 85% de
los bosques del planeta y lograron
firmar también china y brasil esto es
bien bien importante los carros algunos
gobiernos y fabricantes de vehículos se
comprometieron a acabar con la venta de
carros que necesiten gasolina y diésel
para el año 2040 sin embargo los grandes
fabricantes de vehículos del mundo y los
países que los que los elaboran
se han comprometido con esto también la
alianza más allá del gas y del petróleo
liderada por costa rica y dinamarca es
un asunto bien histórico porque han
decidido acabar con la producción de
hidrocarburos e incluso dejar de dar
licencias y la búsqueda de petróleo y de
gas en territorios esto es un paso bien
importante dicen los ecologistas en la
dirección correcta también en el caso de
américa latina colombia ecuador panamá y
ecuador firmaron un acuerdo de
protección marítima de un corredor
marítimo que es considerado el más
grande del hemisferio occidental y no se
nos puede quedar marina por supuesto
esta alianza histórica de la china y de
eeuu que han dejado a un lado sus
diferencias políticas que han decidido
empezar a trabajar como las dos grandes
potencias del mundo en asuntos del medio
ambiente que es sin duda un hecho
histórico marina y por último pues no
hay un texto final pero podemos decir
que la cob 26 se puede considerar un
éxito
[Aplausos]
pues depende de a quién le preguntes por
un lado es histórico el hecho de que si
está en el texto o en el boceto que
hemos visto más reciente la mención a
los combustibles fósiles algo que no
existen al acuerdo de parís así que eso
es algo bastante importante y la mención
de ésta de dejar de lado los subsidios
aunque la palabra ineficiente esté
causando algo de controversia
obviamente hasta ahora sólo estamos un
9% más cercanos a conseguir ese es el
límite de aumento de temperaturas al
grado y medio antes de finales del siglo
así que seguimos encaminados a un
aumento de temperaturas catastrófico
para el planeta para los seres humanos
es decir
hay conclusiones encontradas por ejemplo
hay varios acuerdos también a nivel
subnacional muchas ciudades se han
comprometido a la neutralidad de carbono
así que aunque el texto como tal que
veamos esta tarde o esta noche no sea lo
que todos esperábamos de esta cop 26 si
ha habido avances y poco a poco la lucha
climática de abajo hacia arriba se está
consiguiendo
muchas gracias por este cubrimiento
constante y tan completo desde la sede
de la cob 26 a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en france 24
[Música]